hauptsache nicht erkälten
[Musik]
mein spektrum hat uns gefragt warum die
erkältungswelle eigentlich im herbst
zunimmt und momentan stecken wir immer
noch inhalt hält uns die sorte
hierzulande etwa von november bis märz
dauert die naheliegende antwort wäre
wegen der kälte warum sonst sollte es
erkältung heißen kind tischfußball an
sowie ist doch krank ja ganz so einfach
ist es jetzt auch wieder nicht erst mal
muss man sagen dass erkältungen nur
durch viren und durch sonst nichts
übertragen werden das heißt wenn keinen
ihren anwesen sind dann kann es so kalt
sein wie es möchte
dann fehlt euch die leichter fuß aber
eine krippe bekommt ihr dadurch nicht so
viel steht fest
aber dass erkältungen im herbst und im
winter vermehrt auftreten ist nicht zu
leugnen und diese korrelation ist auch
kein zufall wie ihren besitzen eine
hülle besteht auf sogenannten league
gehen und dieses lied hülle wird im
winter also bei tiefen temperaturen
besonders hart und wird wie eine art
schutzschild für sie so dass sie sich
leichter von mensch zu mensch übertragen
lassen bis du damit sagen dass wir uns
eine schutz nahmen effektiver ist als
das hier im sommer weicht dieser stelle
auf und wird er zu einer art gehen was
die übertragung für regieren dann wieder
schwieriger macht hinzu kommt dass
unsere schleimhäute die als
schutzschicht wirken sollen im winter
austrocknen so dass sich viren leichter
einnisten können
hereinspaziert hereinspaziert
problematisch ist auch dass winterzeit
die gemütliche kuschel zeit s
beziehungsweise wir verbringen viel mehr
zeit drinnen mit anderen
schon in geschlossenen räumen das bietet
viel mehr gelegenheit sich gegenseitig
fröhlich anzustellen hi mein name ist
das gleiche passiert nämlich selbst in
tropischen gebieten nämlich während der
regenzeit wo die menschen auch mehr zeit
drinnen verbringen und wo auch eine
grippewelle zu beobachten ist dass viele
drin sein wird sich in kombination mit
den kürzeren tagen auch auf unseren
vitamin d haushalt aus vitamin d wird
durch sonnenlicht gebildet und hat
unterstützenden einfluss auf unser
immunsystem das immunsystem ist aber
auch noch anderweitig kälteempfindlich
in einer studie soll die teilnehmer
eiskalte shoes bilder nehmen und in den
folgenden tagen vermehrt an
erkältungssymptomen vermutet dass sich
bei kalten temperaturen die blutgefäße
zusammenziehen und das so zum beispiel
weiße blutkörperchen die infektion
bekämpfen langsamer und schwerer
vorankommt bauleute war es gelungen sich
muss auch in heroes bekämpfen
unterstrich karl sagen auch wenn kälte
allein keine erkältung auslösen kann
gibt es doch einige faktoren die mit dem
winterwetter zusammenhängen und die zu
der jährlichen erkältungswelle führen
am besten man verbringt viel zeit warm
eingepackt draußen und legt ein nasses
handtuch auf die heizung damit die nase
nicht so schnell eintrocknet schön
schlau vielen leuten mein spektrum für
deine frage wenn ihr fragen habt
schreibt sie wie immer in die kommentare
und abonnieren nicht vergessen
gibbs zu ihr hatte das schon vergessen
richtig